I just wonder what would happen if one
day like the police raid your home and
like they they bring out all the
evidence you have to go on a watch list
right yeah
so we found a anal lube like two crates
of firecrackers
if I'm a dictator you're on my list like
watch this guy like just keep an eye
like don't do anything weird just just
see what he's holding on Amazon
I think that like I mean
your Amazon order list must be insane
yeah so the Amazon stuff is fine I mean
there was there was a Heyday on on eBay
that was like I kind of missed right
what's this heyday
there was a period in time where you
couldn't get any of those chemicals so
like that's why I was trying to make all
that okay okay then there was this time
where everything was available on eBay
like stuff that was like
nobody should be selling yeah like what
um some of them were like literally just
straight up listed as like uh like I
don't exactly remember which chemicals
yeah but it's like well I think it's I
think one of them's like
I forget no it's not ethanol I think
it's ethanolamine right or something one
of them just made to make like used to
make mustard gas so it's like they're
not really
like they're very heavily controlled
right right
um I think importing it is just like you
can't do it yeah you can actually weird
enough you can manufacture up to like a
kilo I think without a license but you
just can't export it or import it okay
so is that does that happen with a lot
of chemicals you can make your own but
there's surprising a lot about like um
like I give not to golf on a huge
tangible like uh when I was making
uranium glass I really want you to be
careful
that's such a good sentence
you don't know glass okay so I got some
uranium okay
okay that has to put you on a list I
refuse to believe you can buy uranium
and not go on a list so listen so I got
some uranium yeah okay well from where
if you're undisclosed
um no you can buy it like I mean Tech
you can buy in the US you can buy
uranium
and they'll just ship it to you I
actually don't remember where I got from
like I remember what you got you're
right here
I'm like you're not like you know you
remember where you got uranium from you
know how YouTubers have packages
you should get fan packages you're like
oh no the fan box of uranium [ __ ] oh
crap that could have been where it came
from oh my god do fans send you
chemicals no okay I don't really get
anything I have a P.O box but I always
forget to tell people that even exists
right it's been three years
it's just anal lube
yeah okay I was very concerned like for
for a lot of my videos I find that I get
hyped about it and then like right when
the video is done or about to be done I
start to get concerned about the legal
implications
um so like the uranium glass one yeah
yeah I thought I thought it was like
it's cool you make uranium glass but
then when it was done I'm like
is it legal to work what's the
difference between uranium gloss and
regular gloss
it just glows under like a black light
it just glows because it doesn't glow in
the dog does it have like uranium yeah
yeah but like a very small amount
because uranium glows yeah so it's like
some forms of Uranus yeah so nothing to
do with the radiation oh really so this
is the point like I called the
government and I was like I had to call
them it's on speed dial one no I took
actually there's a lot of work to find
the right number yeah right and I called
them and was like is it legal at the
time I was like hypothetic
I wanted to work with uranium
like what's the legal implications and I
was like honestly appalled with what
they told me yeah the guy said
almost all of the laws are related to if
you're using radioactive material yeah
for its radioactive properties but the
glow in the dark it's not glow in the
dark like fluorescent property of
uranium glass is a property of like the
uranium not the radioactive part so
there's
there's nothing we actually they used to
make dials right uranium so that would
be controlled you can't do that oh
really you can't that's radium which is
even worse it's a million times more
radioactive oh yeah the good thing in
watches right yeah yeah and uh
um World War II planes right there for
the finite the paint is like yeah you
don't want to but so if you did that
because the radiation is directly
related to why it glows like you'll get
slapped with with all these regulations
yeah but because the uranium has nothing
to do with the UV under like under a
black light glowing huh he goes there's
technically no law because no one would
no one would be how the who is get it
buying you ain't even doing this right
because no one would do it he goes
because the other one is like for it's
for like nuclear power and all this
stuff he's like these are the they have
laws for Waste Management and all this
stuff yeah yeah and he's like but for
like hobbyists making glass he's like
there's so I asked him like what do I do
with the waste that I made I'm like I
have like papers that are contaminated
with uranium I have like other stuff and
he told me he goes honest sleep I'm
going to tell you by the law
you can just throw it in the garbage
he goes she goes you can just he goes is
it less than a kilo I think and I'm like
well yeah it's like maybe 50 grams he
goes legally you you don't you can just
throw it out and I was like and he goes
but
we strongly prefer if you don't
I'm not gonna make you I'm not going to
make you say it okay
I just saved it because I have like a
little and you put it in like um I have
a little like cabinet for it but he's
just like we strongly prefer you down
that's very sketchy
yeah I'm sure he would probably have
been quite worried so I was going to ask
like either that or like you must have
some lawyer who is absolutely sick of
you who you're like hey we've never
talked like to a lawyer I feel like you
should have a lawyer out of any YouTuber
forget forget look do you have insurance
yeah okay okay good good okay good good
good your insurance bill maybe maybe I
need more after yeah you're like calling
up my Geico like so uranium poisoning
right it was really hard to get
insurance yeah I can imagine [ __ ] it out
like what are you insured against like
actually yeah
what are you what are you listed as yeah
like are you like are you educational
like what is it it was really hard to
like register as a business I was gonna
say right like it must be hard but
obviously you have to do it because you
can't be doing this stuff for fun and
Publishing it and making money right I
wish I could I mean what's actually so
going back even further like when I was
the most sketchy period in time was when
I did everything at my parents house
chemicals were just stored in the room
and it was like just it was pretty yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um and they're gonna say there's one
time a bottle uh I've already gone too
far I have to say I made something
called
um
benzyl chloride I think you've I've
heard about this in your videos it's
like a vague it used to be used as a
tear gas I think it was used in one of
the world wars I don't remember or they
didn't actually make it was it's just
like a tear gas and just irritates your
eyes and the bottles corroded and leaked
into the room with all the chemicals but
that kept that room is nobody goes in it
except my dad goes in there to play
guitar and for like for like we didn't
dad why are you crying no we didn't the
big thing about it is it feels like very
very mild onions right so it's like
there were like for like we couldn't
figure out what it was if we kept
searching you don't breathing-wise you
don't notice anything yeah but it would
be after you're in the room for like
maybe an hour
you just start to get like irritated but
the thing is that it would last for like
hours yeah so like my dad and I for like
a week or two would go to bed I remember
just like tears pouring out of my eyes
and we just didn't know what it was oh
my God who are these ninjas chopping
onions bro but that was that was one of
the big times I'm like I have to just
like this is
right now you have you have your own do
you have your own Labs right yeah like
everything is like up to code that's
crazy that's good yes
I also don't store any chemicals that
like could potentially leak and cause
anything yeah honestly I don't like
keeping those was that like a process
then getting your own place and getting
it all sorted kind of why I mentioned
this when I first started my parents
house I emailed the government and was
like how do I get like a permit to I
wanted to order chemicals and their
answer was kind of like
it doesn't give you anything like
getting getting certified as a lab is
just bad right because they're like what
it allows you to do
is basically have people work there like
it's like it's like you get a bunch of
other like abilities
that make sense in certain businesses
but if you're just doing hobby chemistry
there's no point they said they kind of
what's the difference between you being
like a painter and you buy a bunch of
you want to make your own paints like
what's that different than what I'm
doing mixing solvents doing a bunch I'm
just saying like I get it I get it for
it
I think it's very hard to like make laws
against right so there's actually I
remember I remember talking to a
chemical uh distributor and I caught I
mentioned a chemical license and he
freaked out at me a little bit he didn't
freak out he's kind of like what are you
talking about chemical license I'm like
because you know that doesn't exist
and you can because the license you get
is with individual at least in Canada
individual chemical companies uh and
it's up to their discretion to sell to
you and if it's not on a list of like
prohibited chemicals that like it's like
a drug yeah it's just up to their life
it's liability whether they want to sell
it to you or not so like there's no if I
buy some chemical that's kind of sketchy
like bromine yeah you don't there's no
permit that allows you to own it okay do
you think that should be yeah
no because only the the chemical
companies have like a strong grip right
on who buys who can buy it right I mean
it's so heavily regulated yeah you sell
to like establish businesses